Here is one way to explain the Mapreduce programming
model. Say that I wanted to count the number of
occurrences of each word that appears at least once in
a document. Let's use the text of Alice in Wonderland.
Here's a bit of text that says Alice was
begining to get very tired of sitting by her sister
on the bank And of having nothing to do. If
I wanted to solve this problem without Mapreduce, I might
create a Python dictionary consisting of all the words
and their counts. I could go through the document
and say, for each word in the document, if
there is a key for that word, add one.
Otherwise, set the initial for that key equal to
one. And instead of applying it to this short
sentence fragment from the book, we'd apply it to
the entire book. Before we solve this problem with Mapreduce,
why don't you try to write a Python script
along the lines of what we just discussed, that will
get the job done. Given many lines of a text,
create a dictionary with a key for each word, and
a value corresponding to the count of the word in
that text. Note that we want the words to be
stripped of any capitalization and punctuation. We just want the
basic words. Here's some code to get you started. First,
we import system string. And then we
initialize an empty dictionary, which will hold our
words and values. We cycle through the lines of the input, and for each line we
create an array, data. Which is essentially all
of the words in that line, split by
white space. So if we started with this
line. Hello, how are you? It would become,
hello, how, are, and you, in an array of length four. Your code should go here.
After we split the line by white space, and before we print out the dictionary.